this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream sign
up today and get free access to my new
logistics of d-day series on watch
nebula comm so last month I got to
fulfill a dream of mine
somehow this nerdy boy from the West of
Ireland got invited to fly with the
United States Air Force Air
demonstration squadron known as the
Thunderbirds now you know I'm going to
explain the science and history behind
haiji maneuvers but getting this
firsthand experience with high G really
gave me a better understanding of not
only how it works but how it feels
check this out
[Music]
all right
there's a hundred miles an hour
okay Brian get ready
oh look at that
not about
here comes second Pole
the barkeeper 781 14000 coming once they
definitely do that right
yep definitely didn't do that right
during that vertical climb I reached
about four point six GS there is
literally no scenario in human evolution
that would stimulate the forces your
body feels when a fighter jet decides
it's time to change direction it felt
like my brain was being rewired as it
happened like my brain was trying to go
into the Avatar state and ask my
ancestors for advice on how to deal with
this [ __ ] but not a single one of them
even knew what an f-16 was the closest
any of them got to this level of G's was
when my grandpappy's stood up too fast
in 1932 while digging potatoes and got a
little lightheaded
ironically that is actually your body's
primary response to g-forces when you
stand up gravity will tend to cause
blood to pool in your lower extremities
your body is usually able to deal with
this pretty quickly your nervous system
will detect a drop in blood pressure and
cause your heart rate to increase and it
will constrict your blood vessels in
your legs to raise blood pressure and
get that blood back to where it needs to
be this is how your body has evolved to
deal with normal day-to-day operations
with this this is not a scenario any
animal in the past 4.5 billion years of
evolution on earth has experienced this
is an experience only the genius and
stupidity of man could facilitate when
those G's hit every cell in my body
suddenly weighed 4.5 times more this
wasn't like four and a half people my
weight lying on top of me as the
training told me I have played rugby for
most of my life believe me it's not the
same when even your blood cells weigh
more things get ugly so how exactly do
g-forces develop in an aircraft it seems
intuitive enough but the exact mechanism
is a bit more complicated than you would
expect first we need to set up a
coordinate system because not all G's
are born equally we are going to use my
body as a reference frame here meaning
the coordinate system rotates with me
first we have the most obvious the
z-axis which points directly down
through your body in the same direction
gravity normally wore
downwards is positive G upwards is
negative G this is the one we need to
worry about most when thinking about the
effect on the body then we have the
x-axis which goes laterally through your
body in this case accelerating the plane
will create a positive G in the x-axis
and decelerating the plane will cause a
negative G finally we have the y axis
which extends from the left to the right
of the wing this readout on the heads-up
display is for the z axis airspeed is
here and in miles per hour so how can we
increase G's straight acceleration is
the most obvious we have all experienced
how the acceleration of a carrier will
pushes back into the seats
that's inertia play this is an example
of Newton's first law an object will
remain at rest or in motion with a
constant velocity unless acted on by an
external force the force you feel that
pushes you into your seat is actually
the seat pushing into you and your body
wanting to remain at rest pushes back so
while I was sitting on the runway my
velocity was zero my body wanted to
remain with a zero velocity but the
force of the plane began pushing into my
back to change it creating a positive G
in the G x-axis but that doesn't show up
on the G readout as we said it's reading
the G's in the z axis now look at the
readout as my pilot Thunderbirds seven
lieutenant colonel eric gorni callsign
miami pulls on the stick and shifts our
velocity upwards it spikes to a maximum
of four point six GS in about three
seconds so what happened here if you
look at the airspeed readout it barely
changed if our airs be barely changed
why were we feeling such high
acceleration well because velocity has a
directional component my body had a
velocity pointing directly down the
runway and again thanks to Newton's
first law it wants to remain moving in
that direction but when Miami pulled on
the stick the plane began to rotate and
my body began to push into the seats in
the direction it was originally pointing
creating a positive g-force in the z
axis as displayed on the heads-up
display okay that's all very cool but
I'm not that interest
my immediate thought after this flight
besides feeling a little ill was how
humans who had no prior experience of
flight or high G's learned to cope with
these forces as planes became more
advanced and how exactly planes
themselves were designed to cope with
the immense forces that they were
dealing with now it's quite obvious that
these forces did not suddenly appear too
early aviators the greatest G's the
Wright brothers would have felt was when
they crashed their plane into the ground
in order to rack up high G's in the air
the plane needs to have two things one a
powerful engine capable of reaching a
high airspeed and two a structurally
strong wing capable of resisting the
immense bending and shear loads caused
by high G's the first time pilots really
began to experience higher G maneuvers
was during World War one as pilots
engaged in what the Germans called
Kervin Kampf literally translated to the
turning war in order to fire on an enemy
and win an air battle pilots needed to
turn to get a bead on their opponent if
caught by surprise as often was the case
pilots would need to out-earn their
opponent to get them off their tail if a
pilot could out turn their opponent the
chances of winning the battle was high
and so the battle of technological
superiority to achieve higher G's began
most fighter planes of this era were
either try planes or biplanes primarily
because this offered the structural
integrity needed to turn with higher G's
this provides multiple benefits to
understand why let's first explore the
stresses that develop in a wing during
level flight in level flight the plane
needs to generate enough lift to support
its own weight
this lift will be distributed along a
wing like this
this creates a sheer load diagram that
will look something like this and a
bending moment diagram that will look
something like this with the maximum
shear load and maximum bending loads
occurring at the root of the wing and
this load is multiplied under high G
maneuvers let's look at what happens
when this plane takes a 60-degree
banking turn as it rolls to a 60-degree
Bank its lift rotates with it but the
weight of the plane does not
we need to generate additional lift in
order to support the weight of the plane
this increases our apparent waste we can
break this lift into two components a
vertical component which will need to
equal the weight of the plane to
maintain its altitude and a horizontal
component which will be the component of
lift which will allow the plane to turn
the reaction force to this horizontal
component of lift is essentially
centrifugal force the equation for
centrifugal force is equal to the mass
multiplied by the velocity squared
divided by the turning radius of the
plane this is massively simplified but
it gives us some interesting insights
that will help you understand the
dynamics of flight let's rearrange this
equation to give us just the radius of
the turn if we want to minimize our
turning radius assuming our velocity
component is constant we will need to
increase our horizontal component of
lift or decrease air mass we can do this
by banking airplane more which will
increase the total lift our plane needs
to generate again increasing heir
apparent weighs even more or in other
words increase in our cheese this has
two effects our drag has gone way up in
order to generate this much lift and the
shear and bending forces in our wing of
multiply - as the wing now has to
support the increased apparent weight of
the aircraft and generate enough lift to
hold us these problems were something
early fighter plane designers had to
design around a simple wooden frame
would be severely limited in its
capacity to hold a load like this so
World War one era engineers needed to
get creative with their designs
splitting the wing in two like a biplane
not only shortened the lever arm over
which a bending moment could be applied
but it also increased the second moment
of inertia of the plane the same way an
i-beam allows a steel girder to hold
more weight making the wing shorter also
helped to reduce the moment of inertia
of the plane like an ice skater pulling
their arms into themselves in a turn in
short splitting the workload between
four wings allowed the plane to turn
faster however in massively increased
the drag the wings would generate and
this is where our next problem comes in
even if their wings code would stand the
forces of the turn their engines were
simply too weak to provide the power
needed to overcome the increased drag of
a turn remember when I said to assume
the velocity would remain constant that
can't happen unless you increase power
if the plane has no extra power to give
it will gradually lose airspeed and
stall to combat this these planes would
need to either maintain a larger turning
radius which the plane could handle or
do short bursts of higher G turns so in
practice even if these planes were
capable of holding higher G's their
engines weren't capable of keeping them
there long enough to risk the pilot
passing out this changed in World War
two a stronger light weighs aluminium
alloys came to the fore an allowed
stronger lighter and more aerodynamic
planes while engine power was on the
rise allowing these planes to maintain
higher G turns for longer however the
first pilots to really experience
dangerous high G's were those performing
dives towards the ground like those of
the Stuka dive-bomber this was one of
the first planes to be designed with the
pilots experience with high G's in mind
this plane was developed by Yonkers who
were the first aviation manufacturer to
use jur Allium the new Wonder material
composed of aluminium alloy it with
copper they knew how to design a strong
plane capable of withstanding the G's
from pulling out from a dive by diving
towards the target and locking it in its
sights it is imperative it's bomb with
the velocity it needed to fly straight
to the target with terrifying accuracy
achieving much higher accuracy than a
bomber which relied on air speed and
wind calculations to predict the
parabolic flight from a high altitude
drop however this maneuver came with its
own problems the sukkah was capable of a
maximum speed of 340 km/h in level
flight but in a dive it could achieve
speeds of up to 600 km/h voluntarily
diving at the speed towards the ground
in a plane not designed force was a
death sentence if the plane managed not
to tear itself apart in the maneuver the
without a doubt would black out during
the pull up in order to lower the dive
speed and thus decreased the G's during
pull up the StuCo was fitted with dive
brakes which reduced the dive speed to
450 km/h as soon as the pilot engaged
his dive brakes an automatic safety
measure was engaged that would
automatically pull the plane out of the
dive the moment the bombs were released
at the target altitude this meant that
even if the pilot passed out from the 4
to 6 G's that they experienced they
would recover consciousness to find the
plane in level flight this is basically
the same maneuver we made on takeoff in
the f-16 but in Reverse I experienced
about 4.5 G's during that vertical climb
of about 15,000 feet it was a
mind-blowing experience even after being
briefed on what to expect and what to do
my subconscious mind was just running
through its catalogue of appropriate
reflexes and came up with nothing useful
you are not physically capable of
breathing under this much load as your
diaphragm just can't cope with the
pressure instead you are supposed to
make this short sound every few seconds
to force your epiglottis to open and
allow air to escape while your air mask
forces air in instead I just gasped for
breath you are also meant to tense your
legs to allow the muscle pressure to
force blood out of them I think I did
this but trying to tense every muscle in
your legs while sitting down is a lot
harder than you think that muscle memory
just did not exist for me and would
require more training thankfully I
didn't feel like I lost any vision or
came close to passing out and that may
have been because I had a G suit fitted
these things have air bladders inside
them which the plane inflates when it
attacks G's
this increases the pressure on your legs
and forces blood out and into your brain
and these aren't a new development they
first saw service in World War 2 as
planes like the Spitfire came to the
fore and were capable of sustaining
higher G's in a normal dogfight but they
saw very limited service with only a few
select C fighter pilots ever testing the
Zeus however these pilots were forbidden
from flying over enemy territory in
the Germans captured and copied the idea
pilots like the Seuss and saw its
ability to keep them conscious but the
RAF were not keen on them as they
believed it would encourage pilots to
regularly exceed the recommended wing
loading of the plane and damages this
changed in the Korean War just five
years after the end of World War two
this was the first time jet fighters
were dogfighting and wings were getting
strong too early jet fighters had
similar wings to normal piston powered
engines but that started to change
during the Korean War with wings
shifting towards these delta wing shapes
we are now familiar with take for
example the Gruman f9f panther America's
first carrier-based jet fighter its
wings are a little different to world
war ii airplanes but their aspect ratio
the ratio of the wing span to mean width
is still pretty similar to that of a
Spitfire at 5.7 the Spitfire had an
aspect ratio of 5.6 now look at the
wings of its older brother the groom and
f9f cougar at 3.97 its aspect ratio has
dropped by 30% the f-16 I flew in at an
aspect ratio of 3.1 decreasing the
length of the wing and increasing the
width of the wing like this makes them
aerodynamically less efficient something
the power-limited engines of world war
ii would not have wanted but with jet
engines they could overcome that
additional drag and this triangular
shape provided a much stronger wing
thanks to the load being spread over a
longer wing route and reduced bending
load as the lever arm over which the
lift acted was shorter today planes like
the f-22 Raptor are capable of insane
stunts that pilots of the Korean War
could only have dreamed of this is
simply the greatest air superiority
plane ever made vectored thrust gives
pilots even more power to shift the
direction of the plane without relying
on the wings to generate the directional
lift needed to take a turn IFS has been
designed like all fighter planes to be
unstable to reduce the energy needed to
complete a turn relieving some of the
energy and material requirements needed
to survive a high G turn finally
pilots undergo in
hence of training to acclimate their
bodies to deal with the forces they
experienced centrifuge training became
commonplace in the 1970s to allow pilots
to test and push their endurance while
rigorous training regimes ensure the
pilots have the fitness needed to cope
with the fatigue and stress that
manoeuvres like this put on their bodies
we have come a long way with our
technology since World War two but that
doesn't make the achievements and
actions of these men any less impressive
the technology may have changed but the
human body and mind has not
we have always learned to work with the
tools we had at our disposal to get the
upper hand on the enemy and in the
latest episode of my logistics of d-day
series now streaming on watch nebula
comm the streaming service I created
with my YouTube friends to give us a
safe haven from D monetization and false
copyright claims in the latest episode I
explore the deception tactics leading up
to d-day from the spy networks to the
massive fake armies it's a fascinating
side of d-day operations that is rarely
given the attention it deserves nebula
is now bundled with every curiosity
stream signup you can get an entire
month of both platforms for free and if
you sign up before January 5th you'll
get an entire year's membership for just
1199 that is an incredible price for
access to thousands of high-quality
documentaries like this newly released
documentary titled the search for
Japan's lost super soap chronicling the
search for the missing I 400 class
submarines of the Imperial Japanese Navy
the largest submarines of world war ii
which were built a submersible aircraft
carriers and insane technology that the
United States captured and studied
before destroying all specimens to
prevent the Soviets from being able to
study them $11.99 for a full years
access to both curiosity stream and
nebula is an insane bargain it could
even be a fantastic cheap Christmas
present for your documentary loving
family member or friend as always thanks
for watching and thank you to all my
patreon supporters if you'd like to see
more from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below
you
[Music]